[Music]
welcome to
ear biscuits the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk about life for a
long time i'm link
and i'm rhett this week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're going to be talking about a
birthday surprise that i gave my wife
and i am not talking
you know what i would say you gave it to
me too i gave it to link and we want to
give it to you
as well i'm not going to i'm not talking
about
the big surprise i'm talking about is
not the thing that came out on the the
rhett link channel the vlog
where i became jason mamoa and link also
helped with that
i wouldn't i wouldn't encounter i became
jason
i would say you made a you made a
valiant attempt a cringe adjacent
adjacent basement
that's not a word a cringe adjacent
uh coffee table book where you tried
your best to
uh it is on the coffee table thanks for
noticing oh it uh it no it's not is it i
don't know where it is actually you
don't even know what okay
first of all let me just tell you
because can i say
first of all can i tell you yeah tell me
whatever
that that's not like you said that's not
what we're talking about today
i wanted to clarify what we were talking
about but yeah do that no no i wanted to
clarify what we're talking about when we
say jason momoa because people
may not understand what we're talking
about but we'll come back to that in a
second because we are going to talk a
little bit about that but the main thing
we're going to talk about go ahead
is this gift that you gave her that has
nothing to do with that
that i had very little i'm you know i
made an appearance
he did but like i said he made a cameo
this gift this gift
it's it's it's not that it wasn't the
most specific gift
for jesse that you could give her but
it's just so
it's so enjoyable for everybody it was
so enjoyable for me
it was such an experience i'm telling
him like
over an hour like i had it was like
like the best movie that you've ever
seen wow it was kind of like that was
the experience i had in experience
i've never i've never enjoyed a gift
given to somebody else
more than the how much i enjoyed
that gift that you get what about my
40th birthday party my 40th birthday
this is better no no no way
no no way this is no okay it wasn't that
good but it was
it was pretty great well and one of the
reasons i'm talking about a specific
gift
not a singular gift a singular but my
gift
to jesse my gifts to jesse
were done
considering the fact that she could not
have an actual 40th birthday party now
jessie went out of her way to plan my
40th birthday party like
the d all the details and for why my
party was great
or because of jesse and she loves
parties
she loves people she loves planning
stuff like that
and for years great party because i'm
you know
i'm older than she is i'm three years
older than she is
so for the past three years we've been
talking about how
her birthday party her 40th birthday
party's got to be even better than my
40th birthday party
but of course it's not my fault she
decided to turn 40 in 2020
you know because she turned 40 right at
the end of uh 2020 because it really
crapped that up
and there was all this like conjecture
about whether or not you know
we remember the beginning of the
pandemic when we didn't know what it was
going to be like at the end of the year
well it turns out in l.a it's going to
be it was as bad as it could possibly
get at the end of the year right
so the worst that it's been the worst
that has been it's continuing to get
worse
uh as we're recording this however what
that meant
is that she couldn't have the party that
she wanted and we talked about well next
year we'll do
the whole like delayed gratification
party which will be
one hell of a thing that happens
for people like there's gonna be lots of
people who had weddings birthday parties
and things that they
postponed yeah the party business if you
want to invest in the party business in
late 2021 that's what you should be
investing in
but let's buy a party city i okay i've
always you know every time i go into
party city i'm like
boy i love being in here if party city
can make it
party city would be a great investment
but anyway that's what motivated me to
do
both the jason mamoa thing and the thing
we'll talk about now
and a couple other things but just so
you
if you don't know what we're talking
about if you're listening to this
on the day that it comes out um
two days ago two days ago we did a uh
yeah a vlog a vlog on the red and link
channel link
vlogs that's right but we want to say
that
this is not a harbinger of a lot more
vlogs
uh you know what it's just
this i you wanted to do this thing for
jesse it was
an irresistible idea to document
for for a vlog yeah so we're like that's
what we're going to do
if there's something that we want to
turn into a vlog we're going to do it
yeah so we're not making a commitment
to say vlogs are back what we're just
saying is
we're demonstrating that vlogs are a
thing they can pop up
they can as they as we are inspired and
as we have something to film
um the vlogs the vlog channel is not
dead that's all we'll say but it is not
going to be a weekly thing
but we hope that you enjoyed what what
we gave you
it's a little it's a little and what i
gave my wife unscheduled
treat zone and i will say i i want to
uh i want to put this idea out there i
know we talked a little bit about it
during the making of the jason momoa
vlog just
you can go watch it after this you don't
you can pause it and go watch it right
now but
anyway my wife is really into jason
mamoa
and it's kind of like a running joke and
also as my
hair has grown out uh you know
i wouldn't say that i look like jason
momoa but i look more like jason more
than i did before i grew my hair out
just because he also has long hair
and a beard so there's been this
running joke that i'm trying to be jason
mamoa to my wife
and so we just decided to go all the way
and make this picture book
where i recreated these epic jason mamoa
shots uh which didn't necessarily turn
out epic uh
and i kind of regret putting myself side
by side with him in the book but that
but that is where the most comedy comes
from yeah that's that's
now but what what's what's what's her
relationship with this book you said you
don't
even know where it is anymore yeah well
she has actually it has
a couple of pages have fallen out
because of drool oh gosh
first of all that's a self-deprecating
joke just so you know i'm not i just i'd
never assume that
yeah i'm not she's drooling over
i mean i'm assuming she's drooling over
mama yeah but she has books that are
just him
that she drools over no she doesn't
actually actually she doesn't but i
think now
i know listen i know she has a coloring
book yeah because it was a gift from
your wife right yeah and you know the
thing that christy
christie was asserting that she inspired
she did this whole idea because when she
i don't know if that's
this is your opportunity to she did to
give her some christy
gave showed me the coloring book of
jason momoa which was a lot like the
coloring book that we
like the mythical coloring book like an
adult coloring book but it was no not us
it was jason mamoa
and she was like you should make a
coloring book
of yourself as jason momoa and i was
like
that's a really good idea that's a very
difficult thing to do but you know what
i probably could do
is i could recreate some of his actual
photos
so yeah the idea came from christie's
suggestion to
um do a uh a coloring book but she
she bought jessie the culinary book so
she does own the jason memo coloring
yeah yeah she does but it's you know but
where is the
where's the book you made you really
don't know i mean what's on her bedside
table what what
seriously what what is the lasting
response to it because like you see her
in the video
she's not she you just get her initial
reaction from the vlog
you know she's really getting a kick out
of it it is
it is very funny how it i think how you
like put the
the lines in between it like she she
loved it the fact
that we made it into a video
uh like what she said was
oh i see oh you could you say this is a
gift from me oh
you just wanted to make a video oh now
then she'll follow it up and say
oh i know i'm kidding it's great i like
it
i love it i'm so glad you did it like
but
i mean first of all that's there's a
interesting sort of
we don't have it nearly as bad as like a
family vlogger can you imagine that like
because then at every point everything
that you're doing
there's these split allegiances between
the person you're doing it for and the
audience i couldn't imagine living like
that
first of all yeah because having just
done it you know the few times that
we've done it and in this case very
directly
like i got really excited about the idea
and i knew i could get
you excited about the idea like not to
say that you
you're a great friend but there is no
way in hell you would have done that
without it being a video for the rent
link channel that's an interesting
question
i mean it's just because you would
because you would have been like i mean
man like really we got to do this like
do you do you need me to do this
like not inc and i i'm saying that as
someone who probably would do the same
thing to you
i'd be like is i would like to try to
talk you into something else right
but the fact that we knew it could be a
video it was like you're like all right
i'll do it and i'll
you know i'll kind of adopt a little bit
of a
perspective in the video that i'm really
not into this
uh which i really think worked because i
don't know i didn't know what else did i
i didn't know how i don't know i think
he played it right but
for me the bigger question is uh what no
so to answer your question she was very
appreciative
she was more appreciative of the thing
that we're going to talk about after the
break
i will say that uh because she should be
because
it actually took more work and it was
just for her now we aren't talking about
it on air biscuit
but um we're not gonna we can't let you
can't experience it for reasons that
we'll get into
but the question i want to answer before
we move on or ask
is as we established um
this is an s.a.t question jason mamoa
is to jesse as blank
is to christy and the answer is keith
urban
so i don't know oh no hey listen you
can't walk this back now man
because she's told she's said this many
times it's been a running joke for
years but it started in reality i think
no i think it started
when you might say that you have a crush
on keith urban
and people might just be like oh i get
it which would have been like
over a decade ago so it's a running joke
that has
has continued to run from that amount of
time i really don't think that she's
like
pulling up images of keith urban okay
but like
young keith urban whatever you want to
say at some point
she's still into it i would assume she
hasn't changed like
you know her biological responses to
keith urban to just
raw keith urban
so my question is is that
you know i think that you look as much
like keith urban as i look like jason
momoa i mean
i'm saying like we could easily get your
hair to look like his hair
he's clean-shaven you know what i'm
saying like he has he has i think he
still has
highlights highlights we can do that by
the way i still think he's stuck
in that the phase from over a decade ago
where people would get it
i don't think he's he hasn't tried to
change the question is
and i'm telling you right now i don't
get it by the way and i definitely and i
don't
and i don't get nicole kidman i don't
get them as a couple i don't know
who what do you mean you don't get it
you don't get what people see in keith
urban yeah
well i mean i guess i i don't
personally see it but i think i can
understand i mean i think i can look at
him and tell that like okay
i could see that people would find him
attractive you want me to do a book
i that's the question is i'm willing to
play the role that you played for me
she's already turned 40. well i mean
whatever she turns next
can we do link becomes keith urban and
listen
because it's the second video we'll have
to do something even bigger how do you
know i haven't already done that
in private like how do you know i
haven't done it the right way
well listen i also know that your dad
got a keith urban
electric guitar for himself i went to so
this is years ago i went to my dad's
house for like this was for christmas
years ago and he had a guitar my dad
i've never seen or heard of my dad
playing an instrument and i was like you
got a guitar he was like
uh yeah they were selling this keith
urban learned to play guitar online
it was like a a cheap keith urban
guitar yeah it's just like complete with
the lessons the cheap
fill in the blank celebrity guitar right
i'm pretty confident that he's never
played it
so i don't know between me and my dad we
could uh
yeah we both got some keith urban
connections we both
we're just going to christy's birthday's
in the spring right uh it's in uh
may well we got to get on we got to
start working on this we got to start
thinking
may 13th gotta start i do know the date
um
so anyway i i'm what i'm saying it's up
to you if you want to do it but if you
want to do it if you want to pull the
keith
urban trigger you want to if you want to
pull the urban trigger
just know that i am there to hold the
barrel
i mean that's probably not best analogy
yeah
uh you know i will support you i take
pictures of you
all right so i can't wait to get into
this thing but i i have to get you to
share
the the pizza ordering story that you
told me over the break it's the one
thing from
from the break that i feel like we need
to fill in the gap and i need you to
i need you to tell me that story as well
before the break
after the break oh teaser
okay um you know what we've done
not anytime recently but like years ago
we've set aside a whole section of
amazon.com i don't know what you're
going to say
and we call it amazon.com
and it's a place that you can go if
you're just like i gotta have that prime
shipping
you know i don't want to do i don't want
to wait
i want some things i want things as soon
as i possibly can get them
well the way to do that is amazon.com
mythical now it's a different selection
it's not the same stuff that you get in
mythical.com right
it's different it's a whole different
collection equally mythical
succinctly separate yeah uh so
amazon.com rep your boys over there
compare it to what you would find
at mythical.com um
okay so i want to get to the gift but
like
when you know when we were on our
break and we were separate from each
other we did have this conversation it
was like
you just couldn't wait to tell me this
story but just because you told me
first of all i want to hear it again and
i i i want them to hear it
because it's it's a it's the on beside
the gift
that we're about to get into it's the
best story this is the other bright spot
from the break because the break
you know just to be official about this
the break was
was really laying low yeah you know with
with the covet of it all in la and not
not going out of you know not going back
home
and listen i know just laying low i know
that you do not
come to air biscuits or good mythical
morning or anything else
to hear more talk about the pandemic i
get it we're all tired of hearing about
it
but i do want to talk just i think to
give you some context
about what's happening in los angeles as
we record this right
um the situation is so dire
in in los angeles right now that
if you have to go to the hospital for
any particular reason covid included
the chances of you actually not getting
treated not getting into a hospital bed
are pretty high
right um people are circling uh
ambulances are
circular circling to use the turkey
circling the hospitals and people are
dying
of different conditions covet included
while they're waiting to get into a
hospital
uh and so there's this incredible sense
that like
i mean i told my kids i was like guys
don't do anything stupid i mean first of
all we're already doing all the covid
protocols
and and not going out if you break a leg
but like i'm like if you break a leg i'm
going to put you in a splint i got a
broom
and some duct tape because we're not
weak the chan
they said do not go to the emergency
room unless it's a life or death
situation and i know
the situation is dire in other places
but los angeles has become
the the epicenter of the pandemic at
this point for a number of factors that
we won't go into
but ultimately it's just a it's a really
really scary time
locally and anybody who has said
it's just the flu or
you know what it's not really that
serious it's just a cold
colds and flus do not overwhelm
the hospital system in the way that
covet has
even if there's a very likely high
chance that you're going to survive this
thing
the net effect on a population of people
experiencing covid
is that it overwhelms the medical staff
and the facilities
in the way that it is right now and so
that's why in los angeles in order to
not contribute further to the problem
we're doing everything we can uh to
remain safe so
and to laugh and instead of crying yeah
keep from crying
and that's what i that's what this story
means to me so
again we're not like earlier like even
even just like
two months ago i would go i might take a
trip into the grocery store
to pick something up or if i needed to
go quickly buy something at like the
hardware store i would mask up and go in
right
but in los angeles there's been all
these outbreaks
at retail and grocery stores like we've
clamped back down so now 30 people at so
and so
the ralphs are suddenly infected or
whatever so we're doing like all
delivery we're not going out however
there was a time over the break
where we ordered pizza for we were
trying to order pizza from this place
and we couldn't get them on the phone
and so i was like all right you know i i
i need to get out i'm just going to
drive down there
and i'm going to just order i'm going to
order the pizza in person or whatever
and i go to this place and i look and i
see that
they've got a socially distanced line
for people to order pizza but it's
inside
and so there's probably like i don't
know maybe a total of 10 people inside
this place
including like the staff behind the
counter and then like the people online
and i was on
listen we've been super locked down so
i'm like i'm not comfortable doing this
but you know what
i got my mask on everybody else has got
their mask on it's a limited amount of
time i'm gonna go in but i was feeling
uncomfortable like i was taking a risk
right
so i go inside this place and i get in
line
and i you know i'm in there for like
five minutes or so and move like a
couple of spaces and then i see there's
a couple of
girls who have just ordered their pizza
and are
walking out and they see me
and they recognize me and they say oh
hey
we were just we were actually just
watching you yesterday or whatever i was
like oh great to meet you whatever
now oftentimes when this happens in
public
if you get recognized in public people
who do not know who you are
feel that it is their absolute moral
obligation
to then ask you who you are right it is
one of my pet peeves
it is one of my least favorite things in
the world but hey listen
if it means that things are going well
for us and it's not it's that's what
you're complaining about
your life's pretty good it's a it's a
privileged problem but it's just a pet
peeve that's all i'm saying
so two girls and a guy approximately 20
years old
one of them behind me says excuse me sir
who are you i'm like here we go here we
go and i'm sorry
i'm usually pretty nice almost
always pretty nice but when this is on
edge when this question is asked and i'm
also thinking about the fact that i'm
not comfortable being in here i don't
you know
i said i smiled but you couldn't tell
because i've got my mask on
if you don't know you won't care because
is that not true
it's true is me saying well i have a
youtube channel
that's pretty popular and that's where
those girls knew me from
is how is that going to change this
person's life like you know what i'm
saying it's like
it's just you know it's i know she's
just curious
but it's also an opportunity for
somebody to say they met somebody famous
even if they didn't know who it was
i get it however the only thing that i
can think of as i'm saying
if you don't know you won't care is that
the young man who is with these two
girls
still in his 20s yeah not a boy a man
does not have on a mask does not have on
a mask
now you can call me what you will
you know what i'm saying i know there's
people who listen to this podcast who
think that
masks don't matter and that cove is not
a big deal this story
is just going to piss you off that's i'm
cool with that
um but what i said was hey bro
where's your mask oh you did it you went
there didn't you
and uh was it calculated or was it kind
of a neat job i wasn't even thinking
about it
i was just like this guy doesn't have a
mask on and this is the only thing i'm
thinking about is the fact that i'm not
comfortable being in here because
you know coveted covet basically is
exposure level versus
times time that's how you calculate your
risk level
an exposure level goes up when someone
doesn't have a mask on if they
have it right um so
he's like uh and he this catches him off
guard and then
the girl with him is like well it's in
it's in the car you really should go get
your mask
and i was like you really should and i
said
you should either put on a mask or you
should leave
and he was like he he was like whoa this
guy's really telling me
this guy's really laying it down and i
was like yeah this is serious man
it's like this is a serious thing it's
like it's not hard to put on a mask
and then that was when he was like his
girlfriend had on a mask he was like oh
you oh you're you're from youtube
and and and then um well look i
actually just messed the story up a
little bit because after i said
you should put on a mask or after i said
where's your mask
they said it's in the car and then he
recognized recognized me and said oh
yeah yeah
for youtube and i was like yeah and i
was like um
you know yeah you should put on a mask
or you should leave and that was when he
got really uncomfortable
and i just turned back around you turned
you gave him the back i turned back
around to
keep going in line and also to turn away
from him and that was when he said
unsubscribe i still can't believe he
said that he unsubscribed in public
i mean out loud vocally i've already
given respect because
i mean you criticize people for saying
things in comments that they would never
say
out loud but i never thought that that
which you see frequently in comments
will be something that anyone would ever
say out loud
no i actually appreciate it unsubscribe
like i said it did
did he just he just unsubscribed
verbally he said
do you have to do the work then i don't
know to find his i don't know if he then
if he then brings up his account
unsubscribes however i did like i said
i i wasn't mad i'm not gonna turn into
i'm not gonna i mean there was a part of
me that was like if this guy
really wants to like roll with me about
this what am i going to do because
by this point everyone in the restaurant
was listening to our conversation
because no one's talking everybody's
kind of quiet
yeah and so as soon as i said you should
bro where's your mask it was like a pin
drop kind of moment and people were like
oh this dude's calling this guy out in
front of everybody
um and he was not a small guy and it's
not like i'm a fighter
you know what i'm saying i'm a big guy
but it's not the last time i fought
somebody was
you know john carson in third grade big
or small
us one subscriber is just one subscriber
however he then leaves
oh he did he did he left and he came
back with a mask on and he was like i
got the mask on
and i was like hey and i said i was like
hey i really appreciate that thanks for
doing that
and then that's when he says resubscribe
no no no no he said
mythical kitchen what
so like he made the connection or it was
like
he was racking his it wasn't like he's a
fan it was like i've seen you
on youtube but then his point of
reference was
after he went back put the mask on
thought about it mythical kitchen
and i was just like yep you know i'm not
going to be like well
you know good mythical morning what you
know so um
because it's technically true i have
appeared on mythical kitchen
um so anyway wow unsubscribe
so i really appreciate you know listen
he has every right to unsubscribe if he
doesn't like and you have every right to
unsubscribe to this if you don't like my
my opinion about this stuff if but if i
find you in a public place without a
mask i'm going to
i'm going to talk to you about it that's
just what i'm going to do especially in
los
angeles you know this is serious man
uh i mean how i wonder how many youtube
professionals as we are have experienced
being unsubscribed to verbally
i mean it can't be that many that's
great you think it might be the first
time ever
no no it's happened it's sure but just
to like
just just to say that publicly he didn't
even at that point he didn't even know
what channel
as he proved later yeah yeah right you
know if he unsubscribes from mythical
kitchen because of this i'm sorry josh
um what can i tell you unsubscribe
i mean it's just i like it it's succinct
it goes to the core of
it was very quick thinking on his part
you're well-being you know it's very
very livelyhood
all right but let's get into this um
this gift man okay set up what you did
okay so again jesse couldn't have a
party um
so i was thinking how do i get all the
people
who love her and would otherwise maybe
come to a party
to show their appreciation for her now
the general idea
isn't particularly creative a lot of
people have done this
you make a compilation video featuring
family and friends
saying something that they appreciate
about jesse
and so i was like i definitely am going
to do that but i was like
i don't want to just do the same thing
that everyone else does which is just
get people just to make a compilation
video
it's sweet it's nice maybe she'll cry
maybe she'll laugh
but how do i take this to the next level
now i'm sure
you've heard about the service cameo
which is essentially a service where you
pay
to have a celebrity make a custom
video for you and it varies in price
some people might be 25 i think snoop
dogg is like 900
but you can basically if you like if you
want to get snoop dogg
to wish your cousin a happy birthday or
a happy graduation or give them an
encouraging word or whatever
you can pay and well you just and it's
an app right is it it's a website
it's i think there's there's also an app
they're all listed on there and you can
search
basically by different categories of
celebrity
i mean there's a couple there's a few
youtubers on there uh
but it tends to be mostly
what i would say uh we're not talking
we're not talking a-listers here right
you know you you cannot get
brad pitt to deliver a cameo because
brad pitt's
time is probably more valuable spent
doing whatever else brad pitt does
rather than making
videos for people it's interesting snoop
dogg is the only exception like he
is he's like i wouldn't call him an
a-list celebrity but i wouldn't call him
anything lower either he's like
he's in his own parallel strata
of celebrity that it actually
you know he he'll show up anywhere and
everywhere
yeah but somehow it legitimizes that
thing it doesn't delegitimize him
and who knows i don't know how cameo
works but i mean yes
snoop gets paid each time he does it but
he probably also got a pretty sweet deal
just to go onto the surface yeah maybe
so yeah you know i'm assuming that they
pay
you know people who people would really
demand in order to get i don't know how
it works i don't know the inner workings
of it
all i know is that i was like
a lot of the people on cameo are
people who are known for things like
there's a whole reality tv section right
so you got people who have been on all
these reality tv shows who
you know they're trying to cash in on
their fame a little bit and how easy is
it to just sit down and say i'm going to
re record
10 happy birthday videos for people over
the course of an hour
and make a few hundred bucks or whatever
it comes out to right i gotta think the
covet of it all with people being more
on lockdown with their hands tied
they're not
they're not actively working as much
they you monetize that time the equatio
the equation changes a little bit you
might get people who normally wouldn't
be on there on there
and even if you even though you know the
how it works being that like okay these
people make themselves available
and they then get paid to do a handful
of these however many depends on how
in demand they are i know that they just
sat down and read some facts off of a
screen and did the video and then they
did another video and then another video
but despite knowing that's how it works
it still comes across
as especially meaningful for the person
who receives the video
especially if you don't know about cameo
well i i'd like to
i'd like to explore that in the context
of some specifics because i do have some
observations about
the experience of okay of that but you
have to set up how it happened so
i had two general ideas
right i was like i'm gonna make this
video that's got all her family and
friends in it
and then without telling her i'm going
to pepper in
people that are reality tv stars
meaningful to me and her
or just i thought it would be funny to
have them involved right
and so i will talk about who those
people are and where they're from but
the thing
that i also did is because you can
there's a section where you can write
some personal information
about the person who's getting the cameo
and i was like
how can i make this even more fun than
it's already gonna be
well i'm gonna make up a bunch of stuff
about jessie that's not true
like for instance i'm going to say that
she's turning 40
and she also has 40 tattoos
i'm going to say that she is an avid
juggler
she's an avid fisherwoman uh
she is a mountain climber who has
climbed the following mountains and
whose dream is to climb everest um
she grew up working on a pig farm
and also every birthday she bakes
herself a 12-layer cake
now jessie hates baking she likes
cooking
somewhat hates baking because it's she
doesn't really
like being told what to do or follow
directions so baking is not for those
kinds of people
and uh so it was like the the irony of
saying that she makes a 12-layer cake it
was kind of a little joke between us
so i put this information out there
and then reached out to all the people
who were significant to us and a fair
number of them if not all of them
responded the first person i remember
would you want to get the context for
why you were there when i showed it yes
i forgot that
so um to celebrate jesse's birthday
uh we went away we got an airbnb like
outside of joshua tree just the four of
us you know having already been
a you know a pod when you take the whole
covid stuff into consideration given how
much we have to work together
it's like right on the heels of us
working together anyway
it was a safe it was a safe decision for
the four of us to be together
and um so we're hanging out that night
and she didn't know it
like christy gave her her birthday
present
uh and uh after that you break out the
laptop and you're like i have a birthday
present
for you as well of course christy and i
knew what it was because we contributed
to it as
loved ones and jesse kind of knows at
this point
oh he's he's made a video right
and chrissy's like what rhett do you
uh should we be here for this isn't this
something that's just for jesse
because i mean people say like really
meaningful
things that could be private for her i
don't know they didn't necessarily think
that like
we were gonna be watching this and uh
you were like
no no no i put this thing together and
of course i knew about the cameo part
because you told me i don't think
christy knew
you're like no no no it's like this is
this is perfect to be watched with you
guys so
you know it was in in retrospect i'm so
grateful that like you created this
thing and like i said i loved it it
invited me and christy into the
experience i was watching jesse watch it
for the first time as i was editing it
uh i i knew i knew all along that you
were going to be there that you and
chrissy were going to be there
so when when christy said that like are
you sure you want us to be here i was
like well first of all where are you
going to go
you know we're in this airbnb in the
middle of the desert
but anyway um so
it start the video starts off and you
know i say i've got a little intro and
then some of her friends
uh and actually the last person
right before the first celebrity is your
wife now we're not gonna play any of
these videos because
um i wish we could the funny thing is is
that i'm frustrated
i'm assuming that those people who made
videos for jesse who also listened to
ear biscuits
have probably been thinking up to this
point is he gonna play that video on ear
biscuits that i made privately for jesse
no i'm not gonna do that i would never
do that the only person
who has seen that is of course jesse and
then lincoln christie
um but i um
you cannot show a cameo video now if you
get a cam
i sound like i'm making an ad for cameo
but if if i got
her to make a video if i got somebody to
make a video for jesse on cameo
i could put it on my personal social
media she could put it on her personal
social media
but because this podcast is a commercial
product
technically you know we make money off
this page
against the terms of service i can't
tell you what and or play these videos
for you
but i don't think that's going to ruin
the experience for you because we're
going to talk about some of the things
that people said and just kind of
explore the concept frustrating that
most people when they get a cameo you
know that it's going to be shared on
social media
amongst the circle of friends yeah and
you can tell by the way that certain
people contributed
they they would add certain context or
promotional
statements around it because they know
more people besides this one person i'm
talking to are going to see this
so i might as well take advantage to
like promote my project or whatever yeah
that happened a couple of times
but as you'll see uh on this first one
which the first person to appear in the
video
is uh chris harrison host of the
bachelor
and the bachelorette just you know the
bachelor enterprise
the face of that whole thing as you can
see i zoomed in past
the watermark that says cameo on the
bottom so that the first one that she
saw
she would just think that i had
personally reached out to chris harrison
that's that's the beauty of this if you
especially if you kind of zoom past
cameo you make people think that you've
just arranged this because because chris
harrison basically says
hi jesse your wonderful husband rhett
wanted me to wish you a happy 40th
birthday he's a consummate professional
chris harrison
he's the best he's the best i mean you
know i think the only person
the only person who might do as good of
a job at this is appropsed
i think that jeff props who is not on
there oh he's got he got to be on mine
these guys just specialize in being able
to sit down and just say something that
feels
meaningful but the thing that chris
harrison has is he has a rose
and he gives the rose this rose is you
would you accept this rose or whatever i
bet he didn't give that rose to anyone
right before that video or in the next
video he may write out he's also the
most expensive person on the list i
don't want to
i don't want to disclose the prices but
uh well you said
snoop made was 900 well he's not as
expensive as snoop he's the most
expensive person that i personally
contacted okay uh so chris harrison was
the first one and at this point
because chris harrison first of all
anyone can go on cameo
they can see how much it cost well i
don't know i think he's 500 bucks i just
can't remember
okay exactly the you know everything um
well i'll tell you it was worth it he
was a consummate professional
he made eye contact with the with the
camera lens
he seemed like he was peering into
jessie's soul
hell my soul yeah when i was watching he
also connected to her
uh given her juggling and her fishing
which he
said he enjoyed both of those things
and said we should all get together and
juggle and fish and he had
like he gave her the rose like you know
it's it it was a great bit
other people have other bits yeah
they'll go into okay
so uh the next person who showed up
was uh james the jet ski guy from tiger
king
and he's is he sitting in a golf cart
holding a phone just kind of talking
to her it's very he's out in the open
he's got his he's outside he just
it's like cameo sent him an email
somebody
somebody wants to pay you to to talk to
him he's like oh let me get on it
right now my golf cart i think he might
be relatively
uh so some of the people on the site
have put their past work and you can see
what they say and how they do it
and like he had i mean this i think he's
pretty in demand
but the thing the hilarious the reason i
wanted first of all because we watched
tiger king and loved it
uh the thing that i love about him is at
the end of his cameo
and and my impression based on the other
he was impressed with her tattoos
of course he latched onto the tattoo
thing with the aviators on
you really can't tell that he's reading
some notes
as he it's but you can tell he's like
it's like he's reacting to the notes
he's like
damn 40 tattoos yeah yeah yeah man
and what did he say he was like i got to
give you credit for that
um but it was like he was re it was like
someone was whispering in his ear he
invited her down to florida to ride jet
skis with
him he did that and then and then the
last thing he did he said
you know that [ __ ] carol baskin i think
she definitely killed her husband
that's his clothes that's his like
closing he also says check out season
two of tiger king coming soon which i
didn't even know it was a thing but
again
you found out yeah and now we're telling
everybody yeah that there's a season two
uh but of course i followed up james
right after he said that [ __ ] carol
baskin killed her husband
i followed up with carol basket
[Laughter]
and she says hello all you cats and
kittens or whatever she says
um and then proceeds to because some
people are so entrenched in their catch
phrases they really can't get out of the
fact that they're talking to one person
right now
right so it's you know she's a she's a
vlogger in her own right
well of sorts so she has her vlog and
catch phrases like that
and um but the thing i remember about
carol
is that it got very candid
like she actually you know very personal
she would
she would take some of the notes um like
she really enjoyed
the fact the factoid about the 12-layer
cake oh you make
every i know i understand that every
birthday you make a 12-layer 12 layers
that's a lot
i would really love for you to make me
send me one of those like i would love
to sink my teeth into that and then
she's like but actually
you know what don't send me a cake
because uh i can't eat anything people
send me because there's people who are
trying
who say they're trying to kill me and
she's you know it's she's kind
you can kind of tell this is all top of
mind she's like looking
off a little bit it's top of mind she's
like verbally processing
her own situation it's very
self-deprecating it's very endearing
in connecting but it's like she really
gave of herself
to jessie she had you know she was like
you know what i would love to get cake
from you but
i can't because people are trying to
kill me
right yeah and so there there's these i
never expected it and it happened to a
number of people
where it's like they were able to tap
into a sincerity
and you know i'm doing this video i
might as well be a real person
and then there are more than glimpses of
people
actually being themselves
conversationally
yeah um and you know what it's not an
easy thing to do because as you look
through
all of us who've aren't celebrities on
cameo who made these videos
for jesse you know just the act of doing
it
it you know there's there's a lot of
there's a risk
and there's a you got to check a lot of
your insecurity
when you're not someone who's used to
staring into a camera and making a video
well even when you are someone who's
used to staring into a couch
okay because i see you pulled me up
right after cam i'm hedging right after
carol baskin
link neal and you know what i didn't
even have to pay link neal
yeah what's up with that link neal is
not on cameo yeah
i should have created a cameo um i could
have got a little do you want me to play
this for it for us
because i mean this is the one that you
have the permission to
release i mean no
okay all right i will respect your
privacy no do you i don't care play it
okay jesse happy birthday uh
i want to wish you all the good cheer
and tidings
okay i'm gonna get serious this time i
really want you to have a happy birthday
listen this quarantine thing it sucks
uh has i i don't you know what i i don't
want to talk about
anything negative i want this all to be
positive i'm just that's not right
seriously jesse i just want to wish you
a happy birthday and
um let you know that i value our
friendship
um you know it's it's a it's an
interesting friendship to be
friends because you're married to my
best
friend it's almost like we're um
brother and sister-in-law or something
so love you like a sister
happy birthday hey that was sweet that
was good
it was i really wanted to to say
something honest but then it's like
man why is this so awkward you know
even even the thing i made at the
beginning
uh which was just puts people in which
was basically just like hey baby
whatever you know like i can talk to uh
i can talk to all y'all but when you're
talking to one person
and it's like and then i know that
you're gonna watch it and it's like oh
it's just
it was just a weird confidence and you
know what it caught me at an interesting
time okay
yeah it was late obviously i didn't have
myself together look at me i'm a wreck
it's great it's great um okay i'm gonna
there's a whole story there that i'm not
even gonna go in
just because i i sense how it could be
frustrating to i'm just gonna
i'm gonna just kind of rush through a
few other ones that i included and kind
of tell you why i did
so the trashiest show we've ever watched
together
my wife and i've ever watched together
uh too hot to handle on netflix
where people basically got together at
this resort and you got
penalized by having for having sex and
it was all these hot people who wanted
to have sex with each other okay
um and francesca from that show
um who is just a very distinct
personality
um that and i knew jesse would
immediately it's
basically it was like when you see
francesca
give a happy birthday message to jesse
what it communicates to jesse is like oh
i remember we sat down and we watched
the show together and
just were kind of like horrified by the
people on it but
hey here's one of them wishing you happy
birthday so it's sort of a point of
connection
um then uh okay so i did a whole episode
of your biscuits where i talked about
our obsession with 90 day fiance how
jesse and i just watched this thing and
just couldn't get enough of it well
and i told you about this guy david
who i think is from las vegas and he was
the one that had this
what seemed to be an absolute delusion
about this woman in russia that he was
he was chatting with not even video
chatting with just text chatting with
for
years and he would go to russia multiple
times and every time he went to russia
she would come up with an excuse why she
couldn't meet him and of course everyone
watching knew the excuse was because she
doesn't exist
however the biggest spoiler alert if
you're going to watch that season with
david
uh of 90 day fiance fast forward through
this
but um lana did exist and like the
seventh time he went to russia he
actually met her so i had to include
david
in the in the compilation now one thing
i'll say about david
is uh i don't know if this is because
david hasn't gotten
a like a multitude of requests or if he
just
really invests a lot of time into each
one that he receives he seemed to have a
lot of time on his hands uh
he went for 10 minutes and i did not
include his full
10 minutes in the compilation i took
about a minute or two
and then we watched an extended cut
later in the night um
but he had a whole bit where he was
blowing up balloons and talking a lot
about his
um you know about
his experience with marriage and uh love
and that kind of thing um which was very
insightful
and then it was followed up by none
other than lana herself
yes she's also on cameo so you can do
the david and lana
one two punch and she also again maybe
for similar reasons went for about
10 minutes she seemed to have a script
she was reading
she was very long script she was reading
a speech it was like it was like a
it was like a political speech almost no
it was like it was inspirational
it was very inspirational yeah it's very
inspirational
um but you know catered towards jesse
and then not i mean so you
you get the idea of the novelty of it
and you're like okay you get a kick out
of this
but the thing that i didn't anticipate
was that there's an
extremely powerful overriding
element here and that's when they look
at you
and say your name and include details
and falsified details about your life
growing up on a pig farm
by the way i want to say i don't know if
i personally violated the terms of
service by giving false information but
clearly that can't be it
i mean you can make a joke out of it if
you want to but it doesn't
even though you know how ridiculous and
novel this whole thing is and how fun
it is there's something
there's some the humanity of the
exercise
trumps it all and you find yourself like
actually feeling something like
and not even the moments where people
are being
surprisingly real but just the fact that
they're talking to you there's a
there's a magical engagement when
somebody who you've watched on
television
says your name and starts talking to you
and it's
i mean there's a magic in cameo that i
never thought i would be describing well
and i
i i did include real details you know my
name
her name our kids names our kids ages
our height difference
and stuff like that that's true how long
we've been together how we met all that
stuff
i included so they would talk about that
as well because i didn't want it just be
all fake i just wanted some of the
details be fake
so then we kind of get into the section
of the video where
uh i start peppering in some people that
are just there for my own personal
enjoyment but i know that she will get a
kick out of it as well
because i could only find so many people
who have been on shows that we watched
together
yeah so again i'm a child of the 80s and
was in high school in the 90s so i know
who kato kalyn is kato kaelin is the guy
who was the first person on the scene
after the oj murder
who was in court and he had this hair
and he was this typical like californian
dude
yeah well he's gone on to i don't know
what he's just continued to be cato
caitlyn and he
wrote a song for jesse he wrote a custom
song that like rhymes
my name with things and her name and it
was bad
it wasn't it wasn't a great song but it
was uh i think he knew it was bad and
that was part of it yeah right
uh so i appreciated that um
and then just because my wife is really
you know she is very into the news
can i just say that she's very into the
news okay and so
people who have been in the news over
the past few years for political
reasons or otherwise she's probably
going to be familiar with them and
whatever reason
michael cohen donald trump's former
personal lawyer
who is basically um you know no longer
no longer his lawyer and now a very uh
big vocal critic of the president uh
what was he
sentenced to was he sentenced to
anything i don't know if he he's at home
in the video
i don't know i don't i actually i don't
know i don't know if he
but what his legal situation is at this
time
but i will say he had one of the best
and most encouraging speeches
and it was also very personal and he was
just talking about like
how long he'd been married and you know
i'm not saying he didn't also tell the
story to the next cameo he did
but like it was good and jesse was all
was like
wow that was sweet it was it was strange
to see
michael cohen i mean i remember the
hearings you know
the senate hearings where it's like he
was testifying
yeah and then all of a sudden he's
talking to jesse and he's like
having the most down-to-earth one-sided
conversation that's the beauty of the
service
that's like this is not an ad for cameo
by the way
just so you just so you know i mean we
do i
i would do one because i think that it's
a very f there's no other service like
it as far as i know
but and it worked well for me but this
is just a honest
testimonial um you got this i mean the
next guy
i had heard was on cameo and that he was
like
when a year ago when it started people
started talking about it or whenever
that was
gilbert godfrey's name came up yeah and
here you go you got him yeah i mean of
course you gotta
if go if gilbert godfried is on there
you gotta use him
right i mean he really went with the
whole jesse grew up on a pig farm thing
that was his whole angle and uh he used
it as
kind of a way to question if i was
trying to insult
her because what i said was in my
information i said jesse grew up on a
pig farm and everyone makes fun of her
for it
so he kind of leaned into that and said
i can't believe
that your husband is calling you a pig
and then he was like but if you are a
pig
and he kind of yeah it was kind of like
it was a scathing
stand-up comic it was performance art it
was performance it was uh
it was it was like reverse heckling but
i actually thought he was calling your
bluff that like obviously you made this
up
i thought that was part of that he could
have all he he probably knows that
people do that i think he's the only
i think he is he's been doing it the
longest to know that people make stuff
up you can tell
that he's reading yeah and he doesn't
care but
then he riffs on things that make it
really funny i'm not gonna play this one
but i will say that
uh stevie and cassie had a very uh
produced angle what i mean is like they
they had a bit that they were doing that
i think it really turned out
yeah that was good that was one of the
high points in the video so thank you to
stevie and cassie i don't know who these
women were
then there are some twins uh you might
remember the twins i actually don't
remember their names but they were from
90 day fiance as well
they're like the twins from connecticut
who i think they're getting their own
show
they're getting their own reality show
because they say that in this cameo
so again we've it's this is working
they're getting the twins from
connecticut connecticut are getting
their own reality show
i didn't like them they didn't really
connect with me it's it felt a little
it felt a little canned just because
they talked about how much they loved
it felt like an instagram story they
don't know jesse how do they know that
they love her
um another guy ash who was
from 90 day fiance who's in australia
who was a uh a relationship coach
who seemed to only coach women um
which was an interesting thing about him
uh and then we had
of course everybody's favorite tv show
host aside from chris harrison
and jeff probst mark summers host of
double dare
and here's the thing about mark summers
that was really funny yeah again for the
reasons that you talked about
because these things go out to people he
had all preamble his preamble was
i'm mark summers you may remember me
from double dare
i also did some time with and then he
talks about this
this show did on the food network and
then he talks about the fact that he's
an
executive producer on like guys grocery
games like he basically puts all his
anything that he would talk about at the
end of like a pr spot
he puts at the top of his cameo which is
smart
yeah uh he really went with the he
really grasped hold of the
the mountain climbing and talked about
how she must be in incredible shape if
she's doing all this mountain climbing
and
yeah i think he ended with saying
something like good luck with those
peaks
yeah i kind of felt i kind of started to
feel for these people who are like
basing
who were like regurgitating your lies
yeah i felt bad about that as well but
it was also worth the laughs
now and then we come to it this is uh
okay it's a first of all if there are
any children uh listening to this
particular episode of your biscuits
and you're not comfortable with explicit
talk of sexual acts
um probably probably have them leave
because we're gonna talk about uh this
one i just did for myself
uh and for the juggalos out there
violent jay of the insane clown posse
and i was like i gotta use this guy and
he went
for also 10 minutes now approximately
just
insane clown posse yeah i i had an idea
you know of who i mean they're like they
they wear this
they dress up like these like insane
looking clowns
and i didn't understand the type of
music even though i had watched
like the documentary that the gathering
the juggalos you like
got all these people who are like camp
out and it's this whole community around
it was super
fascinating and super specific but it's
like this
it's they're not metal i get them
confused with
uh slipknot slipknot they're nothing
like slip slip knot is like
like scary marilyn manson and there's
also
is basically just the two dudes and they
just wear they do like
90s bad 90s rap
yeah sort of like a little bit like
house of pain sounding
but yeah but like but not as good not as
good uh
i i i don't know enough to know like
what really connects people to him in
the community so i'm not gonna
but that's just like if you listen to
one song you're like what is going on
here now
in violent jay uh took a very specific
angle
in his video he was in full clown full
clown face
so he gets into character and the
character is uh you know insane
let's just be honest i mean that's the
whole point right so
i did not include the most explicit
parts in the main video because
i didn't want to distract from all the
good loving that she was getting from
people right yeah you know
the as you said the glad tidings and
cheer or whatever you said
so i basically just i kept the beginning
of this video where he just talked about
me and he talked about her and wishing
her happy birthday and how old he was
and stuff like that he had a whole bit
about
how old he was it was nice but
again after the fact we listened to his
entire thing
and that was where at some point again i
think most of this was just
off the cuff at some point violent jay
decided that he was going to talk about
uh his attraction to my wife now i don't
even have any reason to believe that
he's seen a picture of her but i just
think his angle was
i'm going to turn this into me hitting
on the wife
of the i know the husband made this
video for her but now i'm going to talk
about what i'm going to do
with his wife uh and the thing that
really stuck with you
yeah and christy and jesse and me as we
watched this later that
night was the fact that he said he was
going to do
69 69 times with my wife
yeah it's very catchy
and uh boy that's a lot
i want to 69 you 69 times yeah right
yeah i think it's what he said yeah and
he uh he said i was like
fascinating he said other things but
that was really sort of the peak
and that kind of captures the essence of
what he was getting at
he also did some freestyling
yeah it was like it was like this off
the top of the head kind of scatting
and it but he did it it was like a
character trait where he would like kind
of get
manic and start
yeah like a word association
like my like mouth vomit yeah of
of of rhyming words uh that was a bit
scary no i gotta say i didn't feel i
loved it i didn't feel threatened
um my wife tells me that i'm the
i'm very secure in our relationship
because meanwhile he's making a
flip book of side-by-side pictures of
him and you well
here's the thing you know sometimes
jessie will like come back from some
place
in public and she'll tell a story about
like some dude that said something to
her right
and i know that some guys have a
response which is like
where is he i'm gonna go back there and
ask him what he's doing
um but i typically i'm just like good
for you you can't even count to 69.
i'm like that's it's awesome to have
somebody you know hit on you in that way
it just it just reminds you that you
still got it
so when violent jay told my wife
that he wanted to do 69 69 times
and let me just say there was a couple
of times during that night as we kept
repeating it that
sometimes people would say 69 69 ways
but i'm pretty sure he says 69 69 times
because i think 69 is kind of just
that is that is the way that that is the
quote
i mean i'm sure you can do it other ways
but typically it is describing an
action and an act this is the way and he
just wants to do it 69 times and i was
like listen
jesse things ever get difficult if
things get dark
if you begin to doubt that you still got
it just remember that violent jay
told you that he wanted to 69 69 times
and i don't know what 69 times 69 is i
don't do that kind of math
but it's a lot squared it's a lot uh
matter of fact she doesn't have to
remember it she can just pull up the
video
and watch it again we haven't watched it
since though well i mean
maybe she's watched it all right i think
it should be a monthly thing i think
this
on the on the 69th day
of the year you should watch it 69 times
okay that's going to take a while
because
like i said he fully commits if so if
you're again this is a little march
this isn't informative for anybody who
might be thinking about doing a cameo
uh violent jay's gonna go all the way
and he's gonna give you
he's gonna he's gonna go all the way
he's gonna literally he's gonna give it
i i actually have never considered 69
going all the way
okay well i think it might be going past
all the way it might be coming all the
way back around full circle yeah
jaleel white i got him to do it
uh did i do that he was so
did you do that oh he brought up another
fact that i added which was on a golf
course i
said in my false information that jesse
had the largest
insect collection west of the
mississippi river
implying that there was a bigger one
east of the mississippi river
he really went with that and actually
told a personal story
about the time they had a bug collector
character on
family matters and how she was really
attractive and made him nervous
but that after that episode they would
get he would get comments about
bug collecting urkel you know yeah was
in the bug collecting because of this
girl
just little thing that we could have
never known we would have never known
this if i had told her
told him the truth he's also very
inspirational about
you know like this day is the first day
of the rest of your life kind
i don't know if he said that
specifically yeah it was that kind of
inspirational thing
everybody had their their approach yeah
and some people's approach was i'm going
to go into i
i need to be a motivational speaker i
need to say something positive to help
these people out
but they have but they have no
credentials or no business doing that
kind of reminds me of this podcast you
know
i i it was kind of like a ray of
light that these people who
find themselves being listened to
are like you know what i'm going to say
something encouraging
it's going to be hollow and it's going
to be based on like something that i've
read a second ago or that i'm currently
reading
just beside the camera but still you got
to give him
an a plus for f it still means things
there wasn't anybody who was like
they didn't they weren't really trying
yeah was there
was there anybody who you wouldn't get
again well this one the one i'm about to
show you
oh yeah uh he was also a potent i think
the cheapest one the fly on mike pence's
head if you remember one of the if you
remember the vice presidential debate
when a fly landed on mike pence's head
well i think this guy was really trying
to
ride that wave which that wave has
crashed at this point but 15 minutes of
fame
uh he he has a mask he has a fly mask on
and a fly suit on altered voice in an
altered fly voice
and uh he says a lot quite a few jokes
but you know
it was worth a little bit of a laugh uh
and actually that was the last one
that was the that was the last one i i i
edited this thing last minute
and uh so i ended with a fly i probably
should have put him in earlier but
actually
he wasn't the last thing like one of her
close college friends that i knew would
be a big
surprise that i was able to get her to
do it oh yeah they haven't really talked
in a while
that was the one i closed with anyway
jesse was let me just say the the the
effect of this video
now i know we spent all the time talking
about the celebrities
she really really
appreciated it it was great and she
asked me did my therapist
tell you that i wanted a birthday video
like this
and i was like no no
and i was like because
i told him that that's i was hoping that
rhett was doing this for me
i i i hope that he was making a video
because i that because i couldn't have a
party
and i didn't know that i just was like
this is the next thing besides a party
to show like
collective appreciation and you're not
one for
for getting her gifts that she actually
wants that's not you're not known for
that
well matter of fact i don't think that's
my problem as much as it's her problem i
think she has a very high standard
um that's all i'll say uh i have i have
whiffed on some gifts
for sure i've gotten better in the past
couple of years but there was the most
pressure on this one because it was this
milestone birthday
she wasn't able to do the thing but it
really
and i was nervous right because i had
done the jason momoa thing i'd done this
video
um i also got her a bunch of
other like gifts and also the the trip
out of town
uh with you guys was a surprise she
didn't know that was gonna happen until
the day before so
have you paid me for that i keep
forgetting to do that
so that yeah so far it's my gift yeah
yeah
you we went through your airbnb account
i need to do that right as soon as this
is over
um we could pause you could just do it
right now um
so anyway this really works success man
it it really worked can't do it again
though you you know but
she only turned 40 once right yeah when
she turns 50 but you can 69
69 times i could probably get there
before 52.
um yeah so this kind of turned into like
i said it kind of turned into an ad for
cameo
which it's not but i will make that my
wreck
you know i might as well just because
i'm sure that there's another
service or there's there should be
somebody should be getting on this but
cameo kind of guide into this
kind of early in the game and what seems
like this
like you're like oh so again when you
think about the inner workings of it
and somebody's just sitting down doing a
bunch of videos it may seem
kind of empty but when that person
watches the video that you had that
you've made for them especially if they
don't understand cameo as a service
they're like i can't believe you got
this for me i can't believe you did this
it's like so effective so effective i
mean everybody's beginning to understand
but it's still
it's still a pretty great thing i mean
it's still i mean
first of all people do things like get
you
get a star named after you you know what
i'm saying like it's better than that
there's a lot of things that you can do
like oh i got you like an
acre on the moon or a square foot on the
moon or something like that it doesn't
mean anything
but you can like were they going to go
up there i think you did that for me
once actually
i think i've done both of those things
for you as jokes yeah
but the it's a tangible thing that it
results in this video that like i said
you could put on your social media or
whatever and be like
look i got look what this look what
violent jay said about me
and jesse hasn't posted that one on but
she she is free to post any of these on
her social media
yes she is because it's not a commercial
thing so to wrap things up
uh wishing jesse a happy belated 40th
birthday
and uh inviting you to give a wreck baby
wreck baby one two three
four that was my wreck cameo that's what
i just said i'm just making wreck
my cameo correct i had it i didn't
believe that i had another wreck
but oh okay it's hard to come up with
rex so i'm just going to save that for
you yeah
next time i mean my wreck is yeah you
know now you know about cameo if you
didn't know about it you know how it
works
and you know that i use it successfully
so that's my wreck
not a sponsor though maybe they should
be paying us
for real we'll talk at you next week
hashtag gearbiscuits let us know
what you think about all this have you
had a cameo experience i want to hear
that
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best